[Music]
oh we didn't talk about squid game yeah
the finale yeah what do you think I
actually kind of liked it but you know
they haven't paid her yet
mhm so wild I saw that what' you think
of
her I don't know yeah I mean they were
all kind of like I don't know if I like
these people but that was kind of by
Design right yeah I mean it's like all
of them were kind of shitty just like I
just think but she just seemed a little
bit conniving that's all yeah like the
lying about the the Box on the desk
thing like who put the Box on so and
so's desk and she's like it wasn't me I
like that and you're like oh yeah I want
a villain yeah so I like it I like it
but then when you see the villain win
it's a little bit like Ah that's the
thing though all these people can
pretend they're Heroes because they
weren't the ones that won
yeah yeah but they paint her like that
in the editing but the reality is all of
them were ready to [__] each other over
yeah that's true and when people some
people go man my winning just proves to
me you got to be
Savage it's like sometimes you yeah you
kind of have to be brutal yeah yeah and
like playing fair or whatever is just a
stupid concept with this game there's no
fair in that there is no fair if
anything I actually liked
how none of the challenges were really
about physicality a lot of it was chance
and I actually think that was probably
the most Fair way to execute it yeah
yeah totally and even in the end people
going like rock paper scissors what the
hell it's cuz it's chance yeah that's
pretty sick
yeah but
also that I mean I don't know how real
that was in the edit but the fact that
she was counting and trying to count his
choices he's like I'm just winging it
like oh she's like I'm picking up on a
pattern yeah yeah I mean she's not dumb
no I know and I mean I feel like you
have to use anything you can get to your
advantage like even if you're like I
don't know you know trumping chance like
just even a little bit by knowing that
guys throw these more yeah then you
might as well do that yep that's
smart but yeah so I don't think she's a
villain so much as all these people were
like it's not fair it's not supposed to
be fair yeah saw like a Tik Tok from him
about this where he was like yeah we
didn't actually fall was kind of a
bummer they just cheated it with so
stunt person or whatever they'd have
them like drop down like this so they
could edit them falling and then they'd
have someone else come and just jump
down stuff it's probably liability
probably but I would have loved if they
just fell 20 feet on concrete you know
I'm kidding I'm kidding but if they had
a giant foam pit down there would have
been sick yeah yeah I hope they do a
bajillion seasons of this I hope they
just milk the [__] out I watch every
single one they're
casting what they're casting for the
next one yeah yeah we should [__] do
it you would your strategy be I actually
think if I could I would if it was
feasible I would hide in the stall for
like insane amounts of time okay cuz if
I could just be not visible to
people like they just fre or like under
the covers yeah just trying so hard so
that my face is not like people go oh
what the [__] who the [__] is this yeah
yeah that'd be so funny man
yeah yo who the [__] are you yeah just
add you are you a
bombshell I would get a I would get a
top bunk and I would always be on my
stomach yeah so know what actually know
like there's always some like dude up
there but he's like sort of [__] got
a buzz cut yeah I could I could be
anything yeah who is that I have no idea
yeah he's just always up there yeah I
come down periodically you know sus it
out yeah in the middle of the night piss
in the middle of the
floor craw yeah that was another thing
there wasn't a lot of like sabotage like
that yeah you got to do that been great
just on the night Cam you're just
like yeah
what was that farting in your hand were
you wiping your balls
and you can do a little bit of that too
yeah yeah just sprinkle the essence on
someone's
nose the person's
like ohy farted in my face farted in my
face I'd be like I think it was that guy
yeah who are you dude sorry nobody try
to take team captain rolls whenever you
can
get yeah that's the wave be the team
captain yeah yeah either you're out or
you choose someone who's out oh no
yeah no except for the battleship one it
kind of [__] you yeah I think most of
the times it [__]
you n didn't it the battleship
one same also with the uh the guy who
was the team captain for like the the
vomity guy [__] him to
too I liked at the very end like all
like the the compilation or like the
Montage of them like living their normal
lives yeah wasn't that funny it was a
nice little like see it's fine no this
is real look it it's just a game yeah
they're all living happily they don't
need four and half million dollars they
have a dog fine stop it they're in a
kitchen look it you guys said smiling in
this clip come on you guys said we're
bad guys come on look not traumatic at
all look at them eating the dinner on
the dinner plates in their house yeah
they're in slow motion look at they're
fine and then they're on Tik Tok I live
in a car that house wasn't real yeah
yeah yeah that one girl just aced
Battleship yeah it got me so interested
in the probability like per
square yeah cuz I was watching this and
I was like I want to play Battleship
again well that that for sure but I I
looked up like the probability per
square oh what is it it so there's a
there's a site online where due
calculated probability based on 10x 10
so this is 8 by 8 so that's going to
change it okay but according to this
guy's map of
probability your highest probability on
a clean board is actually the center of
the board which doesn't make sense to me
I think it
does because it's like a heat map so did
he run multiple games and then like did
he run like thousands of games no it's
like a probability calculator so you can
like put down where there's a hit and
then it tells you yeah but how would it
know it's I mean everyone has the same
probability you would have to run a
thousand 10,000 games and figure out
where people go the most yeah I mean he
has like a a thing but is that how they
calculated it so so there's this
interesting thing where like the
bathroom stall that's most obvious is
always the cleanest because everyone
thinks that's the most obvious one
people are always going to go to that
one so they don't but everyone thinks
the same yeah so it's always like the
first stall you never go to the first
one but that one is the cleanest because
people always avoid it because they
think other people will go there
actually it's the same thing with the
middle of the board probably yeah and
this guy's actually now that I think
about it what this map suggests is
actually in line with what that girl who
Ace Battleship was
saying she put all her boats to the
edges cuz she's like people tend to put
them more towards the center she said I
thought she said something like that oh
but I thought you just said the opposite
no no no so according to that guy's map
he says your highest probabilities in
the center and I said that didn't make
of winning of of a
hit so if you're striking on an empty
board yeah your highest probability for
hit oh I see okay so it would just be
the opposite of what I said then yeah so
that's why that girl put all she put all
her boats to the edges and she seemed to
do better you think like that's where
people would put their boat so you would
go there you would think but then
actually you wouldn't because people's
theory
is oh you don't want to put a boat on
the edge because like that's obvious ah
yeah yeah and and if they strike the
edge
yeah um we're saying the same thing yeah
but yeah was
interesting also that dude complaining
that his team captain had no strategy I
know it's like what the [__] strategy do
you want them
yeah dude you have no strategy when
playing the lottery
yeah